hey there I am Anna Mac and I like
Japanese cartoons in fact I like
Japanese cartoon so much that i like
talking about japanese cartoons with
other fans of japanese cartoons japanese
cartoons and that is why right here
right now we are announcing that we're
going to be organizing a regular
livestream series called rant cafe
that's right folks sometime soon we're
going to be setting up a regular weekly
live stream called rant cafe where we're
going to be hosting other youtubers as
guests and talking about various
interesting important and controversial
themes inside the anime community we
will have more details for you about the
livestream very soon but the whole
purpose of this series is going to be to
interact and hang out with you guys
right there live on our channel we will
have a general theme or topic that we
will be discussing each week but what we
really want is for you guys to come to
the live stream and tell us in the chat
what you want to talk about definitely
stay tuned for more information because
this is going to be a blast we're going
to have other youtubers a special guests
we're going to be talking about
interesting issues in the world of anime
and we're going to be engaging and
interacting with you guys directly and
in the meantime you guys can join a
special brawl holla live stream that I'm
going to be a part of on twitch tomorrow
saturday at three thirty i am actually
going to be a guest streamer on the
twitch channel of my good friend makel
not the link for his twitch channel is
in the description so definitely check
that out and if you have a twitch
account be sure to follow him he's
awesome you guys know Matt Cole not he's
a really cool guy we've already
collaborated a bunch of different things
with him I mean we're such good friends
now that I already have a bunch of
special nicknames for him big mac mac
and cheese mac man and of course macross
plus little known fact mackall not
Andrew devil had their own anime back in
the 90s and it was actually really good
if you can join us tomorrow at
three-thirty for the brawl holla stream
the link is in the description and make
sure that you follow michael not on
twitch and you can follow anime uproar
too because we're going to be setting up
a twitch stream very soon we're just
trying to figure everything out and of
course stay tuned for more
info on r and cafe because that's going
to be epic epic epic yeah I don't really
know how to do that echo effect so I
just kind of improvised